so this c3 during Microsoft's great
conference advertising the PlayStation 4
we got to see an action pack new trailer
for Dark Souls and it was action-packed
it was fast paced and suited for e3 so
let's go over in a little more detail so
the first thing I was really intrigued
by was this and it's actually one of the
things that made me want to make this
video the character kneels and
extinguishes the bonfire it definitely
looks like it a rush of cold air and ice
comes down now we know you can light
bonfires so I assume extinguishing them
is an option after you light it like
kindling or warping something done
within the bonfire menu but why why
would you want to extinguish a bonfire
they're pretty damn important to the
gameplay and Dark Souls with less
bonfires means Dark Souls with a lot
more traveling and bonfires are pretty
important to the lore as well
remember in Dark Souls the first flame
is fading and so is Quinn's age of fire
but humanity the black little sprite
within every human can feed the flames
the way I understand it Lord Gwyn built
the bonfires throughout his land and
linked them to the first flame every
bonfire has a fire keeper who tends to
those flames when you offer humanity and
Kindle the flames the fire keeper Stokes
the bonfire with your humanity and fire
grows stronger
so Gwyn had a system to keep the age of
fire going
he used the fragments of the Dark Soul
to feed his flame as the undead suffered
through his lands and used his bonfires
to retain their humanity Gwyn benefits
the age of fire benefits and the undead
struggle on so why is it now an
objective to put them out maybe the
bonfires are linked to the curse of the
undead maybe the curse arose when when
linked humanity to a flame maybe it's
his cough says that Gwynn's followers
are shepherding the cursed humans to
sacrifice their humanity for the flame
while Kath would rather have the
fragments of the Dark Soul united in his
hands
wait hands god damn it at any rate I
feel like the undead curse is going to
be a major plot point in one of the
first interviews with edge magazine
shibuya said that the game will revolve
around a cursed character now that's
nothing new but he also mentioned that
they will be trying to find a cure for
that curse he wouldn't be drawn out
further but think about it if anything
is going to be the focus of the game at
this point I think it's the curse
also imagine going through the game with
the bonfires lit then having to go
through with them extinguished it might
make for an interesting gameplay McCann
perhaps it's optional to extinguish them
and you get some other benefit I could
go on for ages but I'll move on so onto
something you wouldn't have noticed
unless you're me enemies seem to react
dynamically or differently to the way
they're hit with a weapon depending on
its type or its stroke maybe it's just
me but this looks like some pretty
insane attention to detail and speaking
of reacting dynamically it looks like
the player character reacts pretty
appropriately as well another example is
this scene when the character runs
through this hallway the enemies spear
glances off his sword even though no
attack was necessarily executed did that
seriously just happen if that's the
level of detail in this game then that's
pretty impressive
alright let's go into a bus fight that
was shown in the trailer and actually
available on the demo that people played
the mirror night the first thing I
thought of was the old monk boss from
daemon souls if you're unfamiliar the
old monk was the first and only Souls
boss that had a PvP aspect in that fight
the player puts on the old monk
headpiece and fights the player who
challenges the boss if you're in offline
mode you fight an NPC and guess what
Maronite has a confirmed pvp mechanic in
this fight the Maronites lands down his
shield leaving himself open to attack
but a player attempts to break out of
the mirror if you let him succeed it
looks like you're up against another
player as well as the boss itself if you
let him do it again it looks like you're
playing two players in the boss oh and
some people thought Dark Souls 2 was
gonna be easy I don't think so prepare
to die is still a valid tagline
speaking of taglines go beyond death was
one of the tag lines that people voted
on on Facebook added the options they
gave us I think this one suits the game
best interestingly they didn't actually
listen to the poll since transcend death
and sacrifice everything were way out in
front if it were up to me I wouldn't
listen to Facebook fans either that's it
soon I'll release a video titled
everything we learned about Dark Souls 2
at e3 so stay tuned for that I'll put an
annotation here when I make it also
before you go the music in the video is
an adaptation of the trailer song made
by Hellkite Drake he remade the song
from scratch replicating every note by
ear and putting it together two hours
after the trailer was released he's a
talented guy find the original song and
subscribe to his channel by clicking the
annotation on the screen later guys
subscribe if you haven't already and
like if you learned something new